being in the military does not make you  a disciplined person  being from a disciplined family does not  make you a disciplined person  being in a disciplined group does not  make you a disciplined person what makes  you a disciplined person is choosing to  be disciplined  so  yeah i i and and also as far as telling  people to man up  um  which  you know when someone says how do i  get up early every day i say get up  early every day how do i stop eating  sugar stop eating sugar  if that's the definition of mana but  obviously it's not just men that need  discipline in their life i don't think i  use that term but what i do tell people  is to get after it  that's what i tell people to get after  it yeah i tell people to do the things  that they know they're supposed to do  right there's things that you know  you're supposed to do as a human being  things that you know are going to  improve your life do those things